CAPITOL FOR A HUGE, ONCE A YEAR
RODEO.
IT'S A TIME-HONORED EVENT
THERE -- AND SPOKE WITH VOTERS
ABOUT CHENEY'S CHANCES.
>> FINISH THIS THING, LET'S GO.
>> Reporter: AT FRONTIER DAYS,
WE FOUND PLENTY OF REPUBLICAN
VOTERS BUCKING THE CHENEY NAME.
>> ARE YOU PLANNING TO VOTE FOR
LIZ CHENEY?
>> CAN I CUSS?
HELL NO.
>> ARE YOU PLANNING TO SUPPORT
LIZ CHENEY?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
LIZ CHENEY RUNNING FOR A FOURTH
TERM?
>> I THINK SHE'S HAD THREE TOO
MANY.
>> Reporter: KEEP IN MIND, IN
2020, DONALD TRUMP WON ABOUT 70%
OF THE VOTE IN WYOMING.
SO, LIZ CHENEY'S WORK ON THE
JANUARY 6th INVESTIGATION ISN'T
PLAYING SO WELL WITH MANY
WYOMING VOTERS.
>> SHE'S DONE US DIRTY.
>> HOW SO?
>> GOD.
LOOK HOW SHE'S DONE TRUMP.
I'M A TRUMP FAN.
I'M SORRY.
>> SO, SHE LOST YOUR VOTE
BECAUSE OF HER ROLE IN THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE AND WHAT
SHE'S DOING ABOUT TRUMP?
>> YES, YES.
SHE'S SUPPOSED TO BE SUPPORTING
HIM.
SHE'S A REPUBLICAN FOR CRYING
OUT LOUD.
>> I FIND HER WORK ON THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE JUST
REPULSIVE.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT HER
WORK ON THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE AND HER ROLE?
>> IT'S ALL A HOAX.
IT'S ALL PROPAGANDA.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
ANYTHING.
IT'S A WITCH HUNT.
>> SHE SAYS SHE'S DEFENDING
WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO PEOPLE HERE
IN WYOMING, UPHOLDING THE RULE
OF LAW.
>> IF THAT WAS THE RULE OF LAW,
WHY ISN'T THERE A DEFENSE TEAM
IN THAT COURTROOM?
THAT AIN'T THE RULE OF LAW.
THAT'S A KANGAROO COURT.
THAT'S NOT THE WYOMING WAY.
>> SHE HAS BEEN AN
EMBARRASSMENT.
IT'S A WITCH HUNT.
>> ARE YOU PROUD OF HER FOR
TAKING ON DONALD TRUMP?
>> NO.
>> Reporter: HERE IN CHEYENNE,
MORE THAN 1,600 MILES FROM
WASHINGTON, D.C., ALMOST
EVERYONE WE SPOKE WITH TOLD US
THEY BELIEVE LIZ CHENEY IS TOO
FOCUSED ON DONALD TRUMP AND THE
JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE AND NOT
PAYING ENOUGH ATTENTION TO WHAT
THEY BELIEVE MATTERS TO THE
PEOPLE HERE IN WYOMING.
>> SHE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT HER
CONSTITUENTS WANT HERE ANYMORE
BECAUSE SHE'S LOST TOUCH WITH
THE VALUES OF THE PEOPLE.
>> I DON'T FEEL LIKE SHE
SUPPORTS HER PEOPLE HERE IN
WYOMING ANYMORE.
THE THINGS SHE'S VOTING FOR
DON'T REALLY REFLECT WHAT THE
PEOPLE HERE IN WYOMING FEEL.
>> DEAN DEXTER IS ONE OF JUST
TWO CHENEY SUPPORTERS WE FOUND
IN THE RODEO CROWD.
>> IF THEY'RE GOING TO BOW DOWN
AND KISS THE RING, I THINK I
DON'T WANT THAT FROM MY
REPRESENTATIVE.
I WANT SOMEBODY WHO HAS THE
CONSTITUTION FIRST AND FOREMOST
IN THEIR MIND.
>> Reporter: WE'VE TALKED TO A
LOT OF FOLKS WHO SAY THAT SHE
HAS LOST THEIR VOTE BECAUSE OF
HER ROLE ON THE JANUARY 6
COMMITTEE.
BUT NOT YOU?
>> NO, IN FACT, I THINK SHE'S
GOT IT EVEN STRONGER NOW.
SHE'S MAKING A SACRIFICE.
SHE IS -- SHE'S MADE A STAND,
AND SHE'S SAYING SOMETHING IS
WRONG.
AND I AGREE WITH HER.
AND EVEN THOUGH IT HAS A
TREMENDOUS PERSONAL SACRIFICE.
>> Reporter: REPUBLICAN SEAN
McKEE IS ALSO A LIZ CHENEY FAN.
>> HOW COME YOU HAVEN'T TURNED
AGAINST HER LIKE SO MANY OTHER
REPUBLICANS.
>> YOU BELIEVE SHE HAS A LOT OF
THAT INTEGRITY ALSO.
SHE WANTS TO MAINTAIN THE
INTEGRITY OF THE STATE.
SHE WANTS TO MAKE IT TO WHERE
IT'S NOT SO MUCH FEDERALLY
CONTROLLED.
>> Reporter: AND WHILE ALL OF
THAT SOUNDS GOOD FOR LIZ CHENEY,
GIVEN WHAT WE HEARD FROM THIS
CROWD, IT MAY NOT BE ENOUGH TO
HAND HER A WIN.
>> I WOULDN'T VOTE FOR HER IF
SHE WAS THE LAST CANDIDATE OUT
THERE.
>> Reporter: ANDERSON, I REACHED
OUT TO THE STATE REPUBLICAN
PARTY TO SEE IF THEY HAD A
COMMENT.
AS YOU KNOW, THEY CENSURED LIZ
CHENEY AFTER SHE VOTED TO
IMPEACH DONALD TRUMP.
THEY DON'T EVEN RECOGNIZE HER AS
A REPUBLICAN.
BUT THE WYOMING REPUBLICAN PARTY
DOESN'T TAKE SIDES DURING AN
ELECTION.
WE ARE NEUTRAL DURING THIS
WE DO NOT BACK OR OPPOSE
CANDIDATES.
IT'S ALSO WORTH NOTING THAT LIZ
CHENEY'S CAMPAIGN HAS ASKED
DEMOCRATS IN WYOMING TO SWITCH
THEIR PARTY AFFILIATION TO
REPUBLICAN SO THEY CAN VOTE FOR
HER IN THE PRIMARY ELECTION IN
AUGUST.
THE STATE PARTY SAYING THEY ARE
COMMITTING